اعلن حزب الله اللبناني عن مهاجمته ثمانيه
مواقع اسرائيليه قباله الحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان وقال الحزب انه استهدف تجمعا لجنود
الاحتلال قرب ثكنه دفيف اضافه الى غرفه
رصد قرب ثكنه شومير مؤكدا ايقاع قتل وجرحى
واضاف الحزب انه استهدف ايضا موقع البغداد
وجنود اسرائيليين في محيط موقعي راميا
والراهب في ثكنه برانيت وقصف بصواريخ
بركان ثكنه زبدين في مزارع شبعه المحتله
كما قصفت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه منطقه جبل
بلاط بالقذائف الحارقه بينما اغار الطيران
الاسرائيلي على محيط ميس الجبل وبين بلدتي
شوكين وجب شيت واصيب مدنيان في غاره على
بلده تورين وتعرض محيط كفر شوبه وميس
الجبل وبلده وعيون لقصف
مدفعي في الاثناء تض ظهر مئات
الاسرائيليين من سكان الشمال والبلدات
الحدوديه القريبه من لبنان في منطقه عامي
عاد قرب مدينه صفد شمال اسرائيل احتجاجا
على الوضع الامني في الجبهه الشماليه
وطالب المحتجون حكومه نتنياهو بالتعامل
الجدي مع تهديد حزب الله كي يتمكنوا من
العوده الى منازلهم وقد تقرر منذ الثامن
من اكتوبر الماضي اخلاء جميع البلدات
الحدوديه الاسرائيليه في نطاق ثلاثه
كيلومترات من الحدود اللبنانيه بسبب
عمليات اطلاق الصواريخ التي يشنها حزب
الله باتجاه شمال اسرائيل ما ادى الى
ايواء اكثر من 70 الف اسرائيلي في
[موسيقى]
الفنادق من بلده رميش جنوبي لبنان ينضم
الينا مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن ابراهيم ومن
الجليل الاعلى تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره
فاطمه خميسه ابدا معك مازن لنتابع المشهد
واخر تطور
وراح نعم في الواقع فدا يمكن الحديث عن
مستويين يتقاطعان عند نقطه رئيسيه ترتبط
بالتطورات العسكريه المباشره المستوى
الاول هو يرتبط بالعمليات العسكريه التي
ينفذها حزب الله اما المستوى الثاني
فيتعلق بالتهديدات الاسرائيليه سواء تلك
التي صدرت عن وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي او
حتى عن المتحدث باسم الحكومه اليوم عندما
قاطع كلامهما على عدم امكانيه العوده الى
ما قبل السابع من اكتوبر هنا عند الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان وتشديده ما على ضروره
تطبيق القرار
1701 هذا الكلام بالنسبه لحزب الله
وبالنسبه للحكومه اللبنانيه لا جدوى منه
ولا يمكن الحديث عن اي ترتيبات على مستوى
الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان لان حزب الله من
جهه وحكومه تصريف الاعمال ايضا متمثله
برئيسها وزير الخارجيه وغيرها من الاطياف
التي تندرج في هذه الحكومه كانت قد اعتبرت
بان اي حديث عن تطبيق القرار
1701 وانسحاب حزب الله الى ما وراء شمال
الليطاني لا يمكن ان يبحث طالما اسرائيل
تخرق الحدود والسياده اللبنانيه وهي تحتل
مزارع شبعه وتلال فرشو وايضا اكثر من 13
نقطه على طول خط الازرق وبالتالي من هنا
يمكن فهم هذا المستوى من التهديدات
الاسرائيليه ان الاذان غير صاغيه هنا في
لبنان لكل ياتي على لسان الساسه
الاسرائيليين او من خلال الوساطات هذا
الامر يحيلنا الى المستوى الميداني
المباشر الذي شاهدناه اليوم وكان هنالك
مجموعه كبيره من العمليات فدا وصلت هذه
العمليات الى تسع عمليات قبل قليل قبل
دقائق اعلن حزب الله عن انه استخدم طائره
مسيره انقضاض لمهاجمه موقع عسكري مستحدث
بالقرب من مستوطنه كريات شمونه وبالتالي
بلمحه سريعه عن مجمل العمليات التي حصلت
اليوم يمكن التاكيد والقول ان حزب الله
استخدم مجموعه كبيره من التكتيكات
والاساليب في مهاجمه القوات الاسرائيليه
انطلاقا من مزارع شبعه حيث استخدم هناك
صواريخ البركان وهي من الصواريخ شديده
الانفجار التي تحمل راسا حربيا يصل الى
نصف طن مرورا بكريات شموه واستخدام
المسيرات الانقلابيه بالاضافه الى تنفيذ
مجموعه كبيره من العمليات العسكريه التي
استهدفت تجمعات عسكريه لجنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كذلك الامر بالنسبه لاستهداف
المستوطنات فيدا هنا لابد من الاشاره بان
التكتيكات التي بات يعتمدها حزب الله باتت
تعتمد بشكل رئيسي على مهاجمه قوات المشات
الاسرائيليين المتواجدين في محيط
المستوطنات
وبعجن يتقاطع عند تاكيدات من حزب الله بان
هنالك اصابات فعليه وقعت في صفوف جنود
الاحتلال في اكثر من موقع لا سيما في شومي
وادمي وا ايفن مناحم انتقل اليك فاطمه
ماذا يفيد الجانب الاسرائيلي عن هذه
الاصابات وكيف يبدو المشهد بشكل
عام نعم يعني اذا ما اردنا ان نلخص اخر
التطورات الميدانيه هنا في الجبهه
الشماليه نتحدث عن انفجار مسيره انتحاريه
اطلقت من الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه الجليل
الاعلى حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم تسجيل اي
اصابات في هذا الحدث سبقه عده احداث كبيره
نتحدث عن قذائف اطلق من جنوب لبنان باتجاه
مزارع شبعه وهذه ليست المره الاولى التي
يتم فيها استهداف المواقع العسكريه في
مزارع شبع المحتله بعد دقائق فقط قليله
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قصفت عده مواقع في
المناطق الحدوديه اللبنانيه كرد على هذه
القذائف التي صدرت من هناك ايضا نتحدث عن
استهداف لكل من بلدتي دفيف واقر قريه اقرث
المهجره اليوم تصدرت العناوين ولكن حتى
هذه اللحظه هنالك رقابه عسكريه حول طفا
تفاصيل هذا الحدث وفقا ما نشرته الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه نتحدث عن اطلاق قذيفه مضاده
للدروع باتجاه بلده اقرث المهجره وهنالك
اصيب اسرائيلي بجروح متفاوته بعد تجمع
الجنود والاسرائيليين في ذلك الحدث تم
استهدافه مره اخرى وبالتالي هنالك ترجيحات
من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي بان يكون حزب
الله قد نصب كمينا لقوات الجنود وفق
الاعلان وفق اعلان الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
نتحدث عن اصابه خمسه اسرائيليين بجروح
المتفاوته ما بين خطيره وما بين طفيفه
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم التطرق الى
مهيه هذه الاصابات هل وقعت في صفوف جيش
الاسرائيلي ام انها وقعت في صفوف المدنيين
الاسرائيليين وبالحديث عن القتلى
الاسرائيليه نتحدث ايضا عن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي اذ بلغ
عدد القتلى من الجنود الى 11 ب جنديا
قتيلا وايضا الى اربعه اسرائيليين مدنيين
لذلك نستطيع ان نرى ان الجبهه الشماليه
شهدت العديد من عمليات اطلاق الصواريخ
المتبادله ما بين الجيش الاسرائيلي وما
بين حزب الله كان ايضا هنالك تحليق كثيف
للطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي في المناطق
الحدوديه وعلى ما يبدو انه كان هنالك ايضا
تنفيذ لغارات جويه في الاراضي اللبنانيه
وبالتالي نحن امام تطور جدا مهم نتحدث
ايضا عن اصابات لم يتم الاعلان عنها بشكل
رسمي ولكن يتم تداولها في المجموعات
الاخباريه وهنا ايضا نرى ان الرقابه
العسكريه تشدد على تفاصيل هذه الاحداث
الامنيه كنا ايضا قد اجرينا جوله ميدانيه
وراينا ان البلدات الاسرائيليه الحدوديه
لازالت مغلقه بشكل كامل وفي مداخل هذه
البلدات تنتشر قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي كنوع
من حاله التاهب الامنيه التي يتم رفعها
الى اقصى درجاتها فاطمه خميسه مراسله
الجزيره من الجليل الاعلى شكرا لك وشكر
موصول لمازن ابراهيم مدير مكتب الجزيره من
بلده رميش